Let's take a look now at how you might optimize some of these landscape materials that you're
creating. So you can adjust landscape so that the further components use a simpler material
for example. You can also activate the landscape modes panel and select the entire landscape.
And then in the details panel under the landscape component, look for the override material
section, which you can see here. So you can press the plus icon next to the array just to add a new
element here and then set the LOD index to one. So the LOD index is one there and then we'll have
a new material that we can plug in there. So you can maybe have a more simplified LOD version of
the material here and you can see that the LOD level one will be further out. And then even if
you wanted four, five, six different LODs, depending on the simplified material, you can
do that and load the landscape there. We also can view this in action. So this is what our LOD may
look like. So we've got good detail close to the camera and really good performance for further
away. So the players or the viewers not going to really see too much difference between the two
materials. But as you can see, there's a lot of complexity going on in this foreground material
and therefore you may not want that being rendered in the distance where the pixels just won't
represent that material. So creating LODs for your materials will be a really good approach there to
optimize some landscape usage. And then we can also talk about distance blending as well. So
distance blending allows you to blend one set of textures into another. So you would want to do
this, for instance, where you have a highly detailed landscape that visually breaks down when viewed
at close distance. So there are a number of different ways to approach this, but the quickest
and easiest is to just use this distance blend material function that comes inside of Unreal.
We can also have a shared source. So if your landscape material stopped compiling, it could
be because you're using too many texture samples. So a sampler is something that tells a GPU how to
sample the textures, whether it's linear filtering, point filtering, wrap addressing,
etc. The D3D11 has a hard limit of using 16 texture samples and it's not something we can
change. So you can use fewer samples in your material by changing the sampler source to shared
shared wrap or clump, which you can see in this image here. Doing this, I will allow you to now
use up to 128 unique textures. So from 16 to 128 into a single material, but don't enable this
right away and only enable it if you need to.